- Martin Bernard derrière
Roberge du côté passager, sont
membres de la section Eclipse du
SPVM. Les deux policiers sont
dépêchés d'urgence dans un motel
de l'est de la métropole.
Le compte-rendu est fait à
leur commandant.
- Quelque chose de particulier?
proxénétisme... Son cellulaire
punch ici. Elle es.
- OK.
- Fait que là, on va aller avec
aux portes. On va essayer dela .
- Après avoir établi un plan
les agents vont rencontrer
la préposée à la réception.réce.
Les policiers Bernard et Roberge
pensent avoir localiséLeurs coét
le pas pour aller les rejoindre.
DAVID PARADIS, combl. section ÉM
- Souvent les gens qui sont
impliqués dans le proxénétisme
sont eux-mêmes armés.
Et le proxénétisme source de ft
qui facilite l'accès aux armes
à feu.
- Cette intervention illustre
bien que la lutte
le trafic d'armes se fait
les policiers de Montréal.
La jeune fille de 15 ans,
traitée par les policiers comme
une victime d'expl
sexuelle. Elle aura accès à
plusieurs services
de policiers, qui retrouvent
leurs coéquipiers
la réunion du soir.
- Car Éclipse, ce sont eux :
une soixantaine de
triés sur le volet, qui
interviennent un peu partout
fonction des renseignements
criminels qu'ils o
Leur spécialité, le crime
organisé.
qui suit découle d'une
information obtenue par
Info-Crime dans un dossier
d'armes à feu.
procéderrrestation,
à son lieu de travail. On évalue
que c'est moins risqué que de
qu'il pourrait être armé à
l'arrivéciers.
MARTIN BERNARD, Policier, membre
escouade Éclipse, SPVM
Info-Crime, les informations
sont... nt très
bonnes. Puis ils sont...
vérifiées par les enquêteurs
et ça peà des enquêtes
un peu plus loin aussi.
Fait qu'on a besoin du public,
pas... On ne peut pas
être pa
- Le commandant David Paradis a
bien hâte de savoir ce qui va
ressortir du Forum pour contrer
la violence armée à Montréal.
- Le SPVt en
son pouvoir pour contrer
ce phénomène-là. Cependant,
il faut comprendre que le SPVM
ne peut pas faire tout à
lui-seulest important
d'avoir également l'apport du
communautaire, l'apport
des citoyens de Montréal.
Donc, je pense que ce forum-là
va avoir la capacité de
rapprocher ces gens-là, puis de
trouver des solutions, qui sont
non seulement applicables au
niveau du service de police,
mais aussi pour la population
dans son ensemble.
- Quant au prévenu arrêté sur
son lieu de travail, il a pa
la nuit en interrogatoire,
pendant que le SPVM, muni
d'un mandat de perquisition,
investissait son domicile.
Ici Pascal Robidas,
Radio-Canada, Mon